alors bonjour bonsoir à la planète ici
tam-tam canada en direct de montréal
cette émission s'appelle également
bonsoir la planète
pour ceux qui ne soit pas les habitués
de cette mission de façon régulière
ici on fait beaucoup d'humour beaucoup
de farce mais on parle souvent de sujets
sérieux comme ce sera le cas aujourd'hui
autour de la table toute l'équipe vous
saluer à la caméra 36 vous celui la
planète bonjour bonsoir
alors on les reconnaît certains d'entre
eux il y aller ou gimeno à la technique
à la technique également il y a marie
claude simard
le petit nouveau vous le connaissez
peut-être pas mais il est c'est un
nouveau membre de l'équipe de l'équipe
arables de radio canada international il
s'agit de samir ben il faut ajouter
quand même ben jaafer diminutif
exactement lé sera besoin elle d'un team
minutes ses fautes non au complet c'est
quoi exactement allait se traiterait
leur 1/4 non je pense un nom
kilométrique je n'ose pas le dire
allons-y avec la liste chantal alléchant
mais c'est pas mon nom à elle chantal
ses deux prénoms des puces mais de notre
famille genève c'est moi quand c'est mon
père c'est quand je dis aux patrons à je
demande à chantal de le faire y dit qui
chante généralement combine les deux
finalistes sont à voile à bien et il n'y
a là qu'un de ce nom là ici autour de la
table heureusement il s'agit de ismael
houda sinon je risque ma troisième
participation à l'émission d'affilée oui
c'est fantastique c'est comme aux zones
et pixar et un record bientôt si vous
continuez je continue et tous ses
membres ici participent à des olympiens
à chaque semaine il ya un jeu en trois
manches
on leur pose des questions sur la
connaissance générale notamment lien
sujet sur le canada et il remporte le
prix de l estime de l'émission
actuellement au prix oui
alors comment ça fonctionne vous ne
savez pas vous le savez aucune idée
alors par contre pour les jeunes c'est
sûr que la boule ne passe pas inaperçue
et a les traits colorier alors ya une
vidéo 5 images tout le monde autour de
la table et c'est devenu le sujet des
missions dans l'espace
et je vous aide pas parce que les images
des fois par la même voie comme mille
mots alors on regarde la vidéo ça qui
marche ce 5000 mots d'un autre chef de
parti si l'immigration l'immigration au
centre de francophonie pour les
immigrants sont utilisation pour on sait
jamais ça c'est un immigrant avec nos
tests d'immigration parfait oui oui ça
va pas ça fait partie de la discussion
aujourd'hui absolument les français l
émigration bas les québécois et
l'immigration élection qui aura lieu le
métier tout le débat d'ailleurs je pense
que vous en êtes tous parlé quelque part
oui à cinq semaines six semaines que ça
dure 30 jours qu'elle a on voit des
images de siby si news notre copain
anglais notre nos amis anglais qui ont
fait des reportages sur les immigrants
ici un mot rien ça c'est un homme qui
est un architecte et il a depuis 30 ans
d'expérience en france pas un seul
emploi depuis qu'il est arrivé au québec
depuis 2013
on a fini par après 3,1 à reconnaître
ses diplômes il a bâti des centres
commerciaux des immeubles appartements
toujours pas d'emploi is a man ray
instinct exemple de ce qui se passe et
ce qui s'est passé ce qui pas français
pour ceux qui pensaient donc fait ses
études en france en ce qu'est ce que ça
peut être oui non parce que des projets
de undead et des politiciens disent
peut-être de prendre une espèce des
examens aux trois ans pour voir s'ils
ont acquis les français ils viennent de
france donc il n'a pas bloqué je sais
pas peut-être je connais des gens qui
viennent de france contre en fait ils
ont eu à passer les tests des français
pour travailler comme le font en anglais
je ne rappelle pas le nom c'est pour
travailler dans les commissions
scolaires pied les français de la france
puis les français du québec qui ont pas
réussi il y avait des dons non mais
c'est sûr qu'il ya des variantes le
procès du québec n'est pas le même que
le français de france il ya des concepts
et qui n'ont de sens de signification
qu'ici quand je vois par exemple
l'expression je suis écoeuré
franchement je suis comme emballée par
quelque chose en france ça veut dire
tout autre chose dans des jeux sports
qui vont jusqu'à ces élections c'est
plutôt dans sa veux dire toute autre
chose dans le contexte français même
hôtesse de français sont préparés en
france corriger en france d'après ce que
d'après ce que j'ai vu we will it est de
la france et quand les gens sont séparés
en france et corrigée en france mais
c'est ça il faudrait les faire en chine
comme tout le reste
écoutez on parle de ça parce qu'à chaque
élection au québec depuis un certain
temps depuis au moins deux sélections
ont pas moins des immigrants et on se
demande la démission aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qui tourne pas rond dans la
tête des électeurs lorsqu'il est
question de l'intégration des immigrants
ils t'ont n'en parle plus directs ont
ici au québec que lors d'élections
provinciales en ontario en
colombie-britannique où il ya pourquoi
beaucoup d'immigrants alors qu'est ce
qui se passe qu'est ce qui est
particulier au contexte politique socio-
politique québécois et culturel
québécois faut ouvrir large la
conversation opté avant de parler de
choses sérieuses non ça on a du fun
ensemble pour paris québécois c'est le
jeu de la grosse boule premièrement
c'est bon pour 20 points un point vous
en faites pas ce n'est pas les 20 points
il ya les 30 points pour la deuxième
manche qui sont disponibles ensuite et
50 points pour la troisième manche
d'accord samir festive oui celle qu'on
destine le plus c'est
c'est donc c'est le petit frère à
détrôner ses concurrents de la table y
avait pas des jeux télévisés avec des
joueurs qui avait des courants au dessus
de la tête
virtuellement accroché non ça me touche
voici le taux de chômage de la
population québécoise en général et 2 je
vous le dis vous aider 5 6%
quel est le taux de chômage des
immigrants âgés de 25 à 54 ans qui sont
arrivés au québec depuis moins de cinq
ans les taux de chômage presse pour 30
de développement du mouvement barre des
deux chiffres c'est super intéressant
jeudi 18% du pour ce 18% 32.2 ces trois
fois le taux de chômage trois fois dit
avec autorité encore une fois c'est bien
moi je vous jettez vous deux là je me
connais le plus proche possible de cette
réponse oui c'est pour ça 13% alors
voyons voir leur taux de chômage
continue de frôler les 14% qui est plus
proche de la bonne réponse est capable
généralement ces trois fous nous avons
envie de gagner ou 20 10 contre et
chaque alors dis pas ça non 20.80
d'une exposition du genre 20.20 pour un
fantastique
alors je peux ce qu'on parle de débat
électoral je pense qu' on vient ici de
mettre les auditeurs les internautes
dans le bain ce qui sera en france par
exemple qui ont aucune idée de quoi on a
discuté durant cette campagne leur
montre à quel point cette question a été
dans rocker de cet instinct christine un
débat je vous propose d'écouter une
entrevue avec notre collègue céline
galipeau jaune est apprécié de tout le
monde je pense
il y est bien au fait des questions
internationales qui aime beaucoup radio
canada international en zone de guerre
aussi elle a fait une entrevue avec
françois legault ce monsieur là que vous
voyez c'est qu'on peut revoir et
embobiner mais c'est monsieur legault
qui pourrait être premier ministre du
québec les sondages le met
né à coude à coude avec le parti libéral
moi je préfére n'y en ai vu jeunes on
est à l'écouté de 50000 à 40 il nombre
d'immigrants pour mieux s'en occuper je
conduis si ce qu'on veut que les
nouveaux arrivants réussi synthèse de
france est un test de valeur avant de
recevoir la sorte scott sélection
maintenant de dix bons actuellement les
différentes étapes ou fédérale avec la
résidence permanente la citoyenneté les
des tests de connaissance du canada ya
des tests d'anglais ou de français bon
y'a une mécanique mais ce qui est
important c'est de comprendre c'est quoi
l'objectif oui mais si vous me proposez
de renégocier au fond cette entente avec
avec ottawa et qui vous l'a maîtrisé pas
il ya quand même quelque chose d'un peu
inquiétant pour les gens n'ont d'abord à
court terme on veut pas rien négocier
avec ottawa ce qu'on dit c'est
l'immigration économique qui est
sélectionné par le gouvernement du
québec donc le seul cas de sélection est
donné par le gouvernement du québec
on veut à l'avenir qu'il ya des
conditions avant que le gouvernement du
québec donne certes cette sélection donc
on n'est pas en train de parler l'aude
comme le dit monsieur couillard en
faisant part au monde d'expulsion on
parle de donner ou non un certificat de
sélection avec son ration qu'est ce qui
va arriver à ce qu'ils passent pas le
test de français tous avec le nouveau
a répondu vraiment à cet instant écouter
dans le fond c'est comme ça se passe à
peu près partout quand on réussit pas
des tests vers n'est pas admis son n'est
pas admis baisse comme un travailleur
qu'un permis temporaires le permis est
échue donc la personne se retrouve sans
statut légal appelez ça comme vous
voulez mais ce qui est important de dire
c'est que nous le gouvernement du québec
on va donner un certificat de sélection
une fois que l'immigrant auront réussi
un test de français et un test de valeur
sinon de ne pas sortir car nous le
gouvernement du québec j'ai des gens way
samir réaction ben écoute moi ce que je
sais une chose c'est que je n'étais pas
préparé à ça mais c'est venu directement
la tendance pendant ces débats
j'ai discuté avec une femme d'affaires
qui en ce moment qui est vraiment elle
va presque fermé boutique parce qu'elles
manquent de demandeurs et andy mais
pourquoi on veut réduire l'immigration
au moment où on en a besoin
bon elle me dit que j'ai parlé avec des
gens de l'entourage de l'homme politique
en question n'ont d'écouter ça c'est
juste pour ramasser le lectorat les
électeurs déçus un peu du parti
québécois et des autres pour les ramener
vers dont il ya aussi une logique
électoraliste
en dehors de ça mais certains pourraient
parler d'un panier d'un panier de
déplorable choses comme ça à discuter
ensemble on va aller faire un
spécialiste j'apprécie beaucoup votre
point de vue vous allez vous mélangez
tout ça la conversation avec rachida
azdouz bonjour rachida bonjour tout le
monde
alors on est très content avoue recevoir
si vous êtes vous êtes une exception
c'est la première fois en deux ans que
nous recevons la même personne à
l'émission good in c'est gentil mais
c'était que c'était une rangée du
reportage je fonctionne l aveugle je
suis kamikazes écoutez au sujet de
françois legault de vous l'avez entendu
quand même durant la campagne électorale
il ya fait multiples déclarations niant
le fait pratiquement à tous les deux
trois jours des déclarations sur les
immigrants et puis l'intégration
il faut diminuer le nom parce qu'on sait
pas les bien les accueillir c'est ça
c'est son message
est-ce que c'est clair pour vous est-ce
qu'il maîtrise ma question c'est assez
clair qu'ils la maîtrisent pas je pense
qu'il ya des éléments factuels qu'il
n'avait pas moi ce qui m'étonne beaucoup
dans ce dans ce débat là et ce n'est pas
la première fois aux dernières élections
également c'est que le tout et tous les
partis politiques confondus parle
indistinctement et indifféremment de
deux phénomènes l'immigration et
l'intégration
on parle pas de la même chose il y à un
fin des enjeux associés à l'intégration
de cordes d'immigrants qui sont là
depuis longtemps dix quinze vingt ans et
qui sont encore dans le corridor qui ce
qu'attendent qui ne sont pas reconnus
par leur ordre professionnel qui
vivotent dans des emplois alimentaire
qui se rapproche dangereusement de la
quarantaine la cinquantaine voire la
soixantaine et qui ne sont pas encore
réellement en emploi ça c'est un
phénomène et le deuxième est celui de
l'immigration
c'est à dire ceux qui ne sont pas encore
là et qui s'apprête à entrer et à
quelles conditions il faut les faire
entrer
donc si nos politiciens tous partis
politiques confondus
they faire un débat sérieux sur la toîle
doivent d'abord distinguer ces deux
phénomènes la l'immigration et
l'intégration parce que quand on parle
d'intégration
on parle de gens qui ne sont plus des
immigrants mais qui sont déjà citoyen
canadien mais qui ne sont pas encore
pleinement intégré des questions autour
de la table à notre invité de la semaine
mais monsieur legault lui il utilise des
peurs qui on pourrait comme ça pensez un
peu loufoque mais qui peuvent être un
peu réel aussi quand il parle par
exemple que il a peur que ses
petits-enfants ne parle plus français
moi j'ai rencontré des gens en région
qui m'ont dit qu'ils avaient peur que
leurs petits enfants dont qui répondent
à des craintes après à savoir si elles
sont réelles ou fantasmées ça c'est pas
moi de le dire mais qui sont quand même
réel chez une partie de la population
n'est ce pas oui au fait moi je pense
pas qu'il faille personnalisé dire
legault quel parti tel parti moi je
regarde ça comme spécialistes très
froidement et je me dis qu'elle est le
parti qui fait une proposition
l'idh est sérieuse indépendamment de
toutes considérations populiste et pour
l'instant je n'en vois pas et il ya ceux
qui tiennent un discours un discours
comment dirais-je alarmistes sur
l'immigration et à ceux qui tiennent un
discours idyllique alors bien ce qu'ils
disent c'est effrayant les immigrants
nous envahissent et nous allons
disparaître et il ya ceux qui disent ils
sont tellement gentils pourquoi vous les
aimez pas les les uns comme les autres
ne répondent pas aux vraies questions et
aux vrais besoins de ces faits sont
têtus je pense par dont la simplicité
dans tous les discours tu ça tue la
conversation battu la réflexion est
injustement jamais posé la question par
rapport au n a pas lésiné madame as 12
oui j'allais poser la question quand
vous dites que les chefs de partis ne
répondent pas aux vraies questions
selon vous les vraies questions c'est
lesquels telle proposition avez vous par
rapport à toutes les déclarations qui
sont entendus jusque là il ya des choses
qui sont récurrentes
claire et je pense que c'est pas moi là
c'est je pense c'est documenté par la
recherche s'est documenté par les
acteurs sur le terrain c'est tout bien
entendu la question de l'emploi il y a
eu une réponse partielle du gouvernement
récemment qui a modifié la grille de
sélection pour encourager plutôt des
emplois de techniciens pour arrimer
davantage la mène le les nouveaux
arrivants avec les besoins du marché de
l'emploi mais ça règle pas le problème
de ceux qui sont déjà entrés tu me
parles qui s'enraye à 10 15 ans et qui
ont encore en toute légitimité besoin de
se trouver un emploi qu'est ce qu'on
fait avec eux soit on les recycle une ça
existe la réorientation professionnelle
il ya des gens qui se sont recyclés mais
il faut le faire il faut leur donner des
formations courtes et l recyclage avec
les moyens bien entendu financiers de
survivre en attendant donc l'emploi
c'est clair que c'est une problématique
est elle est là de tête harry mais
davantage pour ceux qui arrivent mais
faire quelque chose avec ceux qui sont
là depuis 10 15 ans et qui sont encore
en actes de travail et ça c'est un
exemple
il n'y a pas que l'emploi nous nous ne
sommes pas que des travailleurs et des
citoyens et l'immigration n'est pas
uniquement là pour être utilisé à des
fins c'est pas uniquement une question
utilitaires il ya une question
humanitaire aussi il ya des gens pour ne
choisit pas qu'ils sont pas sélectionnés
mais qui y entre par la colle qui sont
des réfugiés
même si le québec n'a pas les pleins
pouvoirs sur ces réfugiés ces gens
viennent quand même au québec il faut il
faut les intégrer ces gens là
certains sont déjà ont déjà des
qualifications d'autres non parce qu'on
sait que les réfugiés ont des parcours
qui font que parfois ils ont dû
abandonner leurs études donc ils sont
pas scolarisés mais qu'est ce qu'on fait
avec ces gens là il faut aussi les faire
travailler donc l'emploi est un gros
chantier
mais il ya aussi les autres chantiers
les relations interculturelles
l'harmonie la lutte contre le racisme la
discrimination tout ça il faut aussi y
travailler ça il ya des solutions
pédagogiques à ça bien entendu alors
donc il ya au moins deux chantiers
pacifié pacifier la société pour éviter
je reviens à la question de heath mais
c'est ça oui c'est ça qui disait il faut
pas il faut pas balayer du revers de
l'anah les peurs légitimes et j'en suis
effectivement il faut pas balayer les
peurs légitimes parce qu'elles sont
légitimes
il faut y répondre et s'il s'agit de
perception erronée et de deux
déclarations farfelues et fantaisiste à
ce moment là on les corrige on dit c'est
farfelu c'est fantaisiste et on avance
des chiffres s'ils ne sont pas farfelue
il faut y répondre est la pire des
choses à faire c'est d'y répondre par
d'autres peur et je ne veux citer
personne en ce moment on a deux comment
dire deux fois menteur de peur qui ce
qui serait depuis seuls qui se répandent
alors à ceux qui disent attention les
immigrants mot menaces il ya ceux qui
disent attention des partis politiques
vont faire du nettoyage c'est
irresponsable
on ne répond pas à une peur paris hopper
d'accord donc en ce moment c'est ça qui
est en train de se passer c'est moi peur
je te fait peur c'est l'halloween
on se déguise
et on fait en sorte les centres visite
irresponsable et tout ça ça vient du
fait que les immigrants vous m'avez
invité alors japon je suis parfois
irrévérencieuse
donc je pense que ce qui se produit
actuellement et à chaque campagne
électorale c'est qu'on parle beaucoup
des immigrants on parle beaucoup pour
les immigrants gars beaucoup de gens qui
parlent à leur place c'est à croire si
ces gens là ne sont pas muet et pourtant
beaucoup parlent le français et de parle
quand même bien en a beaucoup et
l'immigration francophone qui s'exprime
bien même si elle fait des petites
gaffes des genres écoeuré ou ouais mais
bon tout le monde il ya beaucoup de gens
qui et là je parle au temps des
politiciens que des leaders et même de
certains médias on parle d'eux c'est à
dire qu'on parle à leur place on parle
pour eux
on parle donc pour qu'on parle d'eux
mais qui parlent réellement avec chantal
samir est ensuite marie claude
en fait je pense qu'elle a répondu en
partie à ma question parce que vous
dites il faut pas répondre à la peur par
la peur on sait qu'il ya une forme de
repli identitaire au sein de la société
québécoise et donc les politiciens ont
tendance à surfer sur la peur pour
répondre à ces préoccupations sein de la
société en tant que société je sais pas
si vous êtes sociologue ou pas mais je
vous entends ce colloque psychologue
vous ne vous rendez pas mal de sujets en
sociologie
comment donc répondre à cette peur là au
sein de la société
oui alors ya deux choses d'abord
distinguer ce qui est de l'ordre de la
peur et de faire peur au monde à dessein
volontairement pour les peaux par
populisme ça c'est une chose dont qui
ont fait peur en transformant la réalité
et en encourageant et en diffusant des
perceptions erronées volontairement il
faut distinguer sa de préoccupation
réelle c'est-à-dire quand des gens
disent on a peur d'un côté comme de
l'autre qu'il y ait du racisme on a peur
qu'il y ait de la violence on a peur
qu'il y ait une rupture du tissu social
ça
c'est pas de la peur ce sont des
préoccupations réelles et légitimes ils
viennent aussi des fois des personnes
détenues elle-même de l'immigration qui
ont peur d'être victimes de
discrimination hockey autant que de la
société d'accueil caper qui a peur de
perdre des acquis et de verser dans le
communautarisme donc distinguer les deux
caisses qui est de l'ordre de la peur ça
c'est une peur et on y répond en
corrigeant et en donnant des
informations justes étayé et qu'est ce
qui est de l'ordre des préoccupations
légitimes et on y répond par des faits
et on y répond par des solutions on dit
vous avez peur de ça et ce n'est pas ça
c'est une crainte légitime alors pour
prévenir le racisme voilà ce qu'on
propose pour prévenir le repli
identitaire voilà ce qu'on propose des
solutions des solutions pédagogiques
économiques politiques juridiques
donc voilà je pense que la première
chose c'est vraiment de distinguer les
deux de ne pas tout mettre sur le compte
de la peur et de ne pas non plus
entendre des peurs irrationnelles avec
des vraies problématiques qu'ils
appellent de vraies solutions
samir oui madame 12 mois j'ai une
question pour voix à propos de
l'identité pourquoi dès qu'on parle
d'identité tout le monde se crispe à ce
que ce que c'est un péché ou qu'est ce
qui pose problème quand on parle
d'identité
sa première question deuxième question
vous suivait depuis longtemps des
politiques d'intégration à tout ça
qu'est ce que vous en pensez si vous
étiez là chef du gouvernement qu'est ce
que vous allez balle et qu'est ce que
vous allez mettre en avant pour les
politiques d'intégration surtout à
l'emploi tout ça oui d'accord alors
pourquoi l'identité fait peur c'est
parce que c'est un mot qui est l
identité c'est devenu comme les valeurs
cet amour qui a été brûlé brûlé partent
toutes sortes de maladresse et d'usagé
des usages populistes ou des dg des
usages contre-productif du terme
identité du terme valeur et
et même aujourd'hui quand on en parle ça
évoque sa évoque le populisme ça
automatiquement ces suspects que de
parler d'identité alors que de parler
d'identité dans une société c'est tout à
fait naturel
je veux dire on est je disais tout à
l'heure qu'on n'était pas seulement des
travailleurs et des citoyens
on est aussi des personnes humaines avec
des angoisses existentielles avec un
questionnement sur notre propre identité
qui sommes nous où allons nous surtout
quand on est porteur d'identités
multiples il est tout à fait normal de
poser la question d'identité donc en soi
c'est pas c'est pas négatif
mais c'est le fait qu de terre mais été
brûlé par un usage contre productif et
et malhonnête
maintenant je ne serai jamais chef du
gouvernement et je ne serais même jamais
en politique partisane vous avez bien
compris pourquoi parce je dis ce que je
pense mais je crois que ce que
j'attendrais mois de la chef de
gouvernement c'est qu'il fasse une
proposition honnête c'est à dire qu'ils
nous disent qu'elles sont les vrais
problèmes s'ils sont pas capables
d'accueillir 50 5000 immigrants qui le
disent qu'ils disent on va en accueillir
quarante mille 35000 d'accord s'ils sont
capables d'en accueillir 65 milles il
faut qu'ils nous disent que c'est pas
uniquement pour écoeurer parti qui lui a
dit qu'il a il a n'a créé que 36 sec il
faut capable d'accueillir 65000 et ils
ont des réponses neuf qu'on arrête des
instrumentales ise des gens qui n'ont
rien lâché
l'allemagne a accueilli 900 mille
réfugiés en 2015 des principalement des
syriens 900000 comment eux ils sont
arrivés pourquoi nous au québec on ne
serait pas capable d'accueillir un
certain nombre de milliers d'immigrés il
ya quelque chose ici jeu quand on me dit
on peut juste en accueillir 40 mais je
me dis oui mais quand même en est une
grande société il ya beaucoup de gens
ici on est en situation de plein emploi
donc en principe on est capable d'en
accueillir on est en situation de plein
emploi
on est en déficit des mots et
démographique je sais qu'il ya des
démographes qui sont pas d'accord y'a eu
le livre le remède imaginaire donc les
experts s'entendent pas mais le discours
public
bien je ne suis pas démographe c'est
quand même con là on ne sait même pas un
discours c'est des statistiques ons les
une population vieillissante donc on a
des besoins démographiques et
économiques
on est en situation de plein emploi on
n'est pas en situation de crise et de
chômage
donc techniquement on est capable de
l'accueillir c'est sûr que le problème
c'est que les personnes ne sont pas
nécessairement employables d'entrée de
jeu mais ça c'est un faux argument c'est
un faux argument parce que si les
personnes ne sont pas en boule
employables d'entrée de jeu ça veut pas
dire qu'elles sont pas recyclables à
court terme
donc elles sont peut-être pas
employables c'est à dire prêtes à porter
sur mesure mais si on développe des
formations courtes qualifiante et on est
capable de rendre ces personnes-là
employables
même si à l'entrée elles n'ont pas
nécessairement le diplôme ou la
formation en adéquation avec la pénurie
de main d'oeuvre
donc ça c'est un faux problème marie
claude et moi je pense qu une question
importante qu'il faut se poser c'est la
connaissance du français est ce que
c'est vraiment garant elle était
vraiment garante d'une intégration
réussie parce qu'en réalité je pense
qu'on observe que le sucre connaissent
la france s intègrent pas nécessairement
quand mieux que les autres au contraire
ils vont peut-être se replier sur eux
mêmes parce que justement et peuvent
fonctionner seul n'ont pas besoin de
faire appel au tissu social
alors on a remarqué souvent je pense
dans des études que c'est pas parce que
tu parle français qu elles soient
nécessairement réussir ton intégration
très concrète de tout ce que c'est que
ces cohortes successives d'immigrants en
provenance d'afrique subsaharienne et
d'afrique du nord qui était tout à fait
francisé francophones en arrivant et
celik et qui accusait un taux de chômage
alarmant donc qui est allé même dans les
années 2007-2008 jusqu'à avoisiné les
30%
donc c'est une preuve que le fait de et
on ne parle pas de personnes qui avaient
une connaissance fonctionnelle mais deux
personnes qui avaient une maîtrise ce
feu la lampe est donc ça effectivement
je pense que c'est pas c'est pas juste
une impression
ça a été documentée
par la recherche l'autre l'autre point
c'est le grand tabou c'est le grand
tabou de l'anglais c'est qu'on le sait
tous que pour travailler mais elle pour
occuper des emplois alimentaires même
pour travailler chez dollarama
il faut parler aussi l'anglais mais on
se comporte c'est le grand tabou on sait
pas comment nommer c'était défense dans
la pièce qui est que pour travailler au
québec
mais le français est la langue d'usagé
la langue de travail
même si la charte de la langue française
si on veut vraiment travailler il faut
aussi connaître l'anglais et autant par
le bas coûts par le haut pour travailler
dans une commerce au salaire minimum il
faut aussi parler anglais mais pour
progresser dans sa carrière
quand on occupe d emploi un peu plus
valorisant plus gros progressent plus
ont fait face à un problème de langue
c'est bien connu rien il suffit de
savoir d'où j'arrive là-bas et bonjour
[Rires]
yaya ya un pays qui ont été fan a parlé
de l'allemagne qui a accepté un nombre
impressionnant de réfugiés et de
migrants
on oublie un autre pays qui est celui
qui a accepté sur son sol plus de
réfugiés de migrants c'est la suède et
on a vu dernièrement une montée assez
impressionnante
en tout cas des partis populistes et
d'extrême droite est ce qu'au québec
justement pour revenir un peu ici est ce
que c'est est-ce que c'est pas
intéressant est au sens que l'élection
est ce que ça nous permet un peu
d'aborder ces questions là qui peuvent
être extrêmement à chaud et puis qui est
qui qui qui peuvent nous tirailler tous
un peu mais est-ce que c'est pas
nécessaire avant qu'on arrive par
exemple à une situation comme la suède
ou ou un partis populistes ou d'extrême
droite prendrait le pouvoir est ce que
en fin de compte c'est pas mieux parler
de ces affaires l'un deux fronts comme
on le fait avec l'élection actuelle vous
avez tout à fait raison cc je pense que
c'est le sait le la solution pédagogique
c'est qu'il faut aussi on peut pas juste
dire aux gens vous êtes raciste
exactement examine leur qu'il faut il
faut informer les gens il faut leur
donner
non seulement l'information mais des
arts dimanche le rationnel qui sous-tend
l'accueil des personnes parce que là
quand on parle d'allemagne de suède et
nous avec les syriens on n'est pas du
tout dans la même logique que l'accueil
d'une immigration sélectionnés on parle
de réfugiés les réfugiés on ne les
accueille pas pour des raisons
économiques ou démographiques pour les
accueils pour des raisons humanitaires
parce qu'on a signé des conventions
internationales auxquelles on ne peut
pas se dérober et beaucoup de gens du
grand public ne font pas la différence
entre pour elle quand on accueille des
syriens c'est exactement la même chose
que quand on accueille des immigrants
sélectionnés et on se le fait dire moi
je me le fais dire des fois dans les
groupes de formation
ils nous disent mais vous raconter des
histoires c'est pas vrai on fait venir
les gens sélectionnés on accueille des
réfugiés qui n'ont pas de diplôme et il
faut leur expliquer que ça c'est autre
chose qui ne relèvent pas c'est pas de
juridiction provinciale et que on les
accueille aussi parce qu'on n'a pas le
choix on aimerait ça on les accueille
pour des raisons humanitaires
certains membres de la population sont
très à l'aise avec le fait de les
accueillir pour des motifs humanitaires
et ceux qui ne sont pas à l'aise doivent
accepter au moins que si on les
accueille on n'a pas le choix on est
obligé on a signé des conventions juste
faire la distinction entre ces deux
motivations pour l'économique et les cdd
qui coiffe est faux c'est rachida vous
êtes déjà une coéquipière à l'émission
et à ce titre je voulais
exceptionnellement jouer avec vous à
notre jeu de la grosse boule
vous avez déjà 20 points vous avez
remporté le premier jeu alors vous êtes
en compétition avec tous les autres ici
je pense que c'est important quand on
veut parler de ces grandes questions
sérieuses aussi d'avoir du plaisir de
sortir dans son quartier et d'aller
chanter d'aller danser avec les les gens
autour de nous 1
allons-nous on peut pas danser un studio
ne sied pas à cette place c'est sûr
voici notre jeu c'est bon pour 30 points
ça nous fait réfléchir
voici la question il ya un préambule
c'est comme les référendums savez la
capacité des immigrants de parler d'une
des langues officielles au canada le
français l'anglais
c'est une condition importante pas la
seule mais condition importante une
bonne intégration c'est ce qu'on se
pense qu'on s'entend en partie là dessus
alors lors de la tenue du recensement du
canada 2121 premier grand recensement
plus de sept personnes sur dix au pays
qui étaient nés à l'étranger a déclaré
avoir le français ou l'anglais comme une
de leur langue maternelle
quelle est la situation aujourd'hui en
2016 sur dix personnes qui arrivent au
canada
combien ont le français ou l'anglais
comme langue maternelle sur dix
personnes on va commencer avec un judas
bah écoutez si on concède cognant comme
leur maternelle wickram langue
maternelle
donc là on parle on éliminait les
francophones seront gloor de l'afrique
alors c'est les français les belges les
suisses romands
bah oui oui oui ce serait ça c'est ça
donc leur leur pourcentage dans
l'accueil des nouveaux arrivants
il ya les anglais aussi des officiels
sur dix personnes qui arrivent au canada
combien parle donc pour langue
maternelle l'anglais ou le français
l'anglais ou le français et anglais
seraient sur une échelle de 10 oui sur
des personnes sur des immigrants glace
si c'est l'anglais et le français comme
langue maternelle qui la colère car il a
peur des jalles en maternelle loin de 6
sur 10 mais je ne suis pas certaine de
ma réponse précise sur 10 l'humilité et
magnifique alors cessons existe c'est ce
que la note soit 4,4 moi j'irai avec
trois scientifiques mois sera gérée sur
quatre heures on va partager le prix si
vous avez la bonne réponse 3.5 3.5 2000
personnes il faut reformuler la réponse
puisqu'on demande sur dix personnes dont
cinq à 10 3 non j'ai dit trois oui à
quel âge et r2 qui a dit roy alors si
vous la championne
ces trois personnes hantées ça illustre
le fait maintenant que l'immigration
vient de toute la planète
la planète pas seulement de certains
pays comme l'angleterre et puis c'est
vrai que l'amérique du sud via les
chinois on est une sorte de communauté
c'est vrai dit rien ouais l'échangé des
africains des insulaires du pacifique
que toi et à toutes sortes de personnes
qui rentrent ici et qui viennent de
toutes parts à travers le monde rachida
en terminant je vous demande pas de
délire un gagnant lundi vous pouvez pas
le faire seul comme ça mais pouvez vous
me dire si un parti qu'elle est partie
qui va faire le plus de gains en ayant
présenté en ayant parlé de la question
de l'immigration et de l'intégration
durant les dernières semaines celui qui
va faire le plus de gains auprès des
électeurs qui va être disons les coder
sensibilité québécoise le plus à ce
niveau là que faire des gares moi j'ai
l'impression que cc c'est presque et je
dirais que québec solidaire pourrait
faire des gains avec l'immigration mais
avec toutes les marges
parce que c'est quand même le parti pis
pour les plus vulnérables les marges
dont québec solidaire pourrait faire des
gains entre autres avec cette question
là le parti libéral pourrait aussi faire
et je pense que le parti libéral est
déjà a déjà une longueur d'avancé dans
pourrait aussi faire des gains avec
cette question là mais ils ne vont pas
faire des gares pour les mêmes raisons
écoutez c'est tant mieux que d'aller à
l'université suivre un cours
super merci beaucoup rachida d'être
revenu nous voir cette semaine avec
plaisir
bonne semaine à tous
alors c'était donc rachida azdouz
psychologue et spécialiste des relations
interculturelles
pour ceux qui ne savent pas je ne savais
pas et elle occupe actuellement le poste
de conseillère principale du
développement stratégique au
vice-rectorat aux affaires
internationales et à la francophonie à
l'université de montréal
un titre qui presque aussi long que le
vôtre ça me samir ben pour faire court
faire quoi c'est ça écoutez on est prêt
pour le dernier jeu oui on va on va
faire une récapitulation au niveau des
scores parce qu'il ya eu souvent du
cafouillage dans le passé où des gens
qui étaient des perdants vous laisse
désigné gagnant
donc on fait le tour et moi c'est très
simple c'est 0,05 an à 70 30
ça fait 7 mai 00
alors les filles elles ont pris un bain
de sang voyez qu'elle va encore être la
championne avec la compagnie cette
semaine veut nous donner les réponses
elles
voici ses ventes par 50 points si vous
avez zéro peut-être que vous pourrez
arrivé au moins deux filles doit d'abord
selon statistique canada et ses données
recueillies sur les migrations et la
diversité ethnoculturelle de l'or
toujours du recensement 2016 d'accord
quel pourcentage de population au canada
a déclaré être ou avoir déjà été la
régie d'arrêt de la discute avec eux
cette question un immigrants reçus ou un
résident permanent en 2016 on a demandé
à tous ceux qui étaient au canada elle
vous dit j'ai été ou êtes vous encore
quelqu'un qui est nouvellement arrivés
ou anciennement arrivée au canada
je simplifie les choses pour rachida
donc la proportion pour centrer sa haine
ouais ben oui répond pas pourcentage
puiqu'il plus proche de la bonne réponse
il pourra pas donc à voir
j'imagine plus qu'un gagnant ok donc
l'intention des immigrants sein de la
population canadienne
on était huit pour cent oui pour son
hockey en 8 %
pour lui coûter le canada est un grand
pays d'immigration et pour ça comme ça
c'est sûr que c'est un droit de vous
aider à l'examen moi je dirais 35 pour
ça 35% allez hop à 27 pour cent pour
cent 19 à 20% 19 36 36 c'est bien vous
avez tous les deux la bonne réponse
on coupe un peu a laissé 21 29% poche
j'ai dit un objet divin
donc c'est vous ce sol et n'importe
j'avais tous les 2 50
bravo deux gagnants on ne pas passer
beaucoup de vidéos l'émission parce qu
on avait tellement des propos des
raisins 35 en 2003 6 on va être autour
de 32% ouais ok qui était déjà aux
facultés dans le passé et micro augmente
dans ses terminaux faudra reposer cette
question en 2030 c'est ça va mieux se
préparer au québec un je vous dis on
n'en restera plus beaucoup de baby boom
sont nés après 1945 ory rions pas ses
seuls
alors écoutez je vais vous présenter
quelque chose de nouveau à l'émission
parce que on est capable de faire plus
que 2-1 ce sujet d'accord moi ça m'a
frappé vous peut-être que ça chapeau du
tout c'est ce que j'appelle le segment
faut pas montré à la caméra faut
regarder par regardez pas il n'ya que
notre webmestre ici qui connaît la
réponse
voulez vous connaissez la réponse c'est
l'image de la semaine je sors question
où l'image la semaine moi je ne peux
répondre que par oui ou par non
donc j'ai dit le moins possible à nadine
québécois ve intervention je répond par
oui ou par non
est-ce que c'est au canada non c'est aux
états unis
le juge à la cour sur la pousse pousse
en même temps c'est l'accusatrice
c'est ce que j'avais dit mot sinon ou
les
victime dit c'est mon image la semaine
c'est les nations unies qui rit de
donald rang ça aurait été drôle ça c'est
une bonne réponse mais pas la seule que
j'ai c'est très bon c'est pas au canada
c'est ça s'est passé c'est pas au bout
je répond par oui ou par non
ok est-ce que c'est au canada non est-ce
que c'est aux états unis oui c'est
contre hugo sera proche de tromper qui
ça aurait pu être bon non mais c'est
magnifique ses réponses on continue j'ai
vu les images peut passer par la cour
suprême
non hein c'est pas les nations unies qui
se moque d'eux n'atteint sinon c'est
artistique ça fait le tour du monde
c'est palace et le cirque du soleil
abdallah à ryad en arabie
non j'ai beaucoup aux états unis le tour
du monde oui oui c'est régulier je peux
vous aider
je veux bien sûr ça va lier au show bis
oui céline dion c'est fini pour elle
oui ce sera fini bientôt pierre du côté
de la technique
peut-être sa chanson non non ça aussi ça
aurait pu être bon show biz ghomeshi la
lettre de gommer chine et aux états unis
mais c'était le new york
il ne reste que cette édition coacher
notre piste justice et chemise a répondu
qu'elle la cour suprême
oui vous avez vu l'image ou si c'était
moi je lui à 4,5 le matin en pleine
noirceur je suis pense que aux gars
parce que peu importe ce qu'il a fait il
a 81 ans
il marche avec une canne et des aveugles
et les chanceux et il a été il est
chanceux la grande vedette américaine à
la division est chanceux d'aller en
prison tout de suite parce que dans son
état il aurait pu il aurait dû aller
plutôt en prison ouais jeunes en tout
cas awilo réduit il aurait dû la trappe
est beaucoup plus c'est clair que c'est
un prédateur sexuel n'y a pas
d'hésitation c'est pas comme l'histoire
de cavanna on sait pas trop qui quoi non
mais j'ai dit parce que moi le
témoignage il ya plein de fou là-dedans
on sait plus où on se situe par rapport
à kavala on se situe par tous les jeunes
mais rien mais rien que ça aurait dû le
discréditer en tant que juges suprêmes
de votre façon aujourd'hui donc d'un 30
dans une heure et six minutes cette
ville avez vous un communiqué envoyé au
sénat aux sénateurs il ya deux élues
républicaines qui n'ont pas encore donné
leur choix c'est elle qui vont décider à
la fin pas votée elle doit voter l
ancien moquer c'est de ne pas voter avec
les démocrates
alors sera élu chef oui mais qu'est ce
qui va arriver
ces sénateurs la république 1 ils sont
ma vue dans leur parti les élections de
mi-mandat s'en viennent c'est très
risqué pour le parti républicain
de quoi de faire qua non pour les
républicains de voter quand le poste de
juge à la cour suprême pour les
accusations dont il est présumé s'est
risqué que ce n'est pas une seule femme
qui se plaint mais certains vous diront
que c'est une manipulation politique qui
a dû du trafic politique derrière sa
tête des produits sont extrêmement
nombreux là dessus on met le principal
intéressé l'a d'ailleurs dit dans une
nuit c'est ça il est victime d'un
complot
et quand il a dit ça mais j'ai entendu à
la radio c'est sorti comme une tonne de
briques du monde juillet il adopte une
opinion politique alors que c'est un
juge
et moi je dirais que ça détonnait avec
ce que de la neutralité tout à fait
judiciaire je suis c'est pas hyper sa
place là c'est par une cour de justice
cette commission dont connaissez mais
ces réactions sont exactement les mêmes
que bill cosby qui parlait de complot au
début od de one thing qui parlait de
complot au début tous ont parlé de
complot et qui finalement
oui tant qu'ils sont encore dans le sac
mais être accusés sans cour de justice
quand même s'était lui-même juin on a un
exemple qui contient tous quelque chose
de dieu il ya quelque chose qui te
quitte parce que je pense qu'on est à un
moment charnière ici peu importe pour le
mouvement mis tout pour le le palais
républicain et démocrate il ya quelque
chose de lui aujourd'hui un papier sur
le sur la prince où je pense que marie
claude lortie fille dit que en
maintenant le les témoignages de femmes
devient crédible
habituellement quand ça témoigne
directement oui c'est un complot mais là
apparemment ce qu'a dit par rapport au
témoignage de l'accusatrice du juge elle
dit que c'est ça devient crédible que je
sais pas si vous voulez devenir vous
allez voir ça je vois capable j'ai posé
la question c'est pas de savoir s'il est
coupable ou pas la question c'est de
savoir est-ce qu'il peut être nommées
juges et je sais pas un tribunal qu'on a
à faire c'est une nomination
donc forcément c'est un poste important
et c'est un poste très important c'est
le plus important on était tout à fait
mais là vous êtes des points de vue
rationnel mais je pense pas que c'est
comme ça qu'on évalue qu'on analyse la
situation nécessairement présentement à
washington je pense qu'il ya en tant que
juge à la cour suprême si le ciel va
l'attaquer en justice après elle donc ce
que ça va pas le décrédibiliser dans son
poste après si elle décide d'aller
jusqu'à la cour suprême je crois qu'ils
sont intouchables ils ont une immunité
président qu'elle gagne c'est spécial
imaginons que madame ford ou docteur
freud comme on peut l'appeler du vrai
essayons d'imaginer qu'est ce qu'elle
vit en ce moment qu'est ce qu'elle a
vécu à travers cette journée de
témoignage là puis ça ne porte à penser
comment souci de vraiment de la guérison
de défendre qu'en réalité c'est comme
complètement hors champ sa dimension là
on n'en parle pas du tout c'est comme
notre côté du maroc que tu peux faire à
quelqu'un qui essaie d'apporter la
justice mais de guérir aussi
complètement évacué la question s'il est
véritablement coupable s'il ne l'est pas
quelles sont les motivations on parle de
politique mais de vraiment la motivation
personnelle que quelqu'un irait vraiment
met là il faudrait du temps
qu'est ce qui pousserait une femme à
passer à travers les menaces de mort
c'est la question que tout le monde se
pose parce que généralement quand on se
lance dans ce genre d'aventuré il faut
être sûr d'avoir tous les éléments de
preuve
généralement le fardeau de la preuve
repose il est donc dans le cas de la
dame
je trouve qu'il ya beaucoup d'éléments
qui manque déjà se souvient pas de
certains détails de sa cdc des
perceptions et des questions précises
présentes qui les ont vus est ce que
c'est quelque chose que je ne comprends
pas que je suis
rappelez-vous les 17 mars à côté de la
chambre n'est pas une question de
perception nous on explique je sais même
pas si c'est des tapas publique de
montrer ces choses là parce que c'est
vraiment des c'est pas à nous de juger
de ça c'est des gens qui sont en la
forte que moi je me rêve de rien j'étais
toujours plein d'alcool
[Rires]
c'est facile à imaginer quand tu vis un
traumatisme comme ça que tu te souviens
pas nécessairement puis en supportant ce
genre de candidats que fait donnacona
président on décrédibilise les grandes
institutions et où l'on rit de lui à
l'onu qui est une grande institution
qu'il veut discréditer qu'il a dailleurs
discrédité plusieurs fois dans son
discours
et il va jusqu'à même discrédité les
grandes institutions de son pays en
supportant des candidats qui aurait dû
dès le départ être enlevées ou de
trouver un remplaçant c'est aussi le
travail de sape que le président fait au
sein des institutions américaines qui
est assez mais il l'a fait déjà ça fait
quelques semaines a aussi a dit que
lesdites et
les bears et c'est vraiment il ya aucune
logique
j'ai une amie qui dit que l'intégré
stennicke il est au pouvoir
[Rires]
alors écoutez on fait le tour de la
table merci beaucoup je vois qu'on va
ramener cette question de l'image de la
semaine mais je me trompe d'image vous
trouver quand même la bonne image sur
laquelle débattre fantastique alors ça
me remercie vous voulez revenir parce
que vous avez si vous venez vous avez
aussi une émission à faire en arabe je
me dis ouais c'est pas toujours facile
mais si vous la porte est ouverte si
vous voulez revenir je vous enverrai
toujours une invitation vous répondez
par oui ou par non pas oui votre cash
antalya pas oui mais c'est au delà de la
grosse boule sérieux à la alors il ya
personne qui est obligé de nerfs
émission il ya que moi est monté à
quelqu'un il manquerait effectivement
quelque chose alors ça me remercie
beaucoup
mais si samir ben oui les copains et
puis ismaël merci beaucoup merci à vous
un chantal alice mieux connue des gens
de chantal c'est plus facile pour moi
que alice au pays des merveilles
merci beaucoup et bien par sa banque et
des quoi était ce que devrait être
administré en chine on se souviendra de
nous ne cherchons sociale merci et puis
on dit mort voir l'athlète quelle caméra
on l'aide de caméras
on va planer
[Rires]